and you're younger than me yeah
what is hi I'm Vanessa I'm a baker and
today I'm going to be trying to guess
people's ages based off their dessert
preferences I think the hardest part is
going to be those people that kind of
have old tastebuds but they're super
young and I might get their ages mixed
up it's going to be a little bit of a
challenge that's okay so we've got
oatmeal raisin over here which i think
is the world's worst cookie so I'm gonna
put this in an interesting age range
that this is probably someone in their
late 40s maybe 50s um their favorite ice
cream is vanilla and their favorite
chocolate preference is a brownie and
people in their late forties early
fifties loved alamode type of things a
lot of movies in like the 80s and 90s
like we know the girls are crying and
she's upset she usually picks up
something with alamode like she'll she
won't just grab like an apple pie or a
brownie she'll pop some ice cream on it
so that's like a total generational type
of thing so this is their least favorite
which I think it's fruitcake people in
there like pastor ladies love fruitcake
and this means that their parents
probably forced them to eat food cake
all the time and now they hate it so
that makes us their cake or pie
preferences cake cake people are
adventurous people they're a little more
non-traditional in a sense of pie people
it's it's fun cake it's fun you can't go
wrong with a good cake so I think this
person is definitely a fun person but
looking at everything I have decided
that this person is 45 final answer 45
hi I'm Jana and I'm 56
oh my god but I'll take 45 I think your
assessments were really really really
good people don't like oatmeal so I
always get the cookies at a party and
that people pushing it on you and having
an old cake that you keep giving away
for sure I like 45 I'll take it okay so
this is contestant number two we have
their favorite cookie which is oatmeal
raisin which last time I get some reason
I gave them an older age range but I
think I'm gonna give this person I don't
know I'm gonna come back cuz I really
don't know I really don't know okay so
their favorite ice cream is chocolate
the traditional flavor is vanilla so
this person is definitely a little more
fun I think I'm gonna start putting this
into an age range of mid 30s that's
that's where I'm starting I don't know
many young kids that like chocolate ice
cream right now but I do know people
like my age and maybe a little older
that like chocolate ice cream and I also
don't million people that are older that
like chocolate ice cream they've got a
brownie here of course who doesn't love
brownies this kind of throws me off a
little bit I'm not really sure where to
place this this is really hard I'm
definitely struggling more with this one
because it's such a random array of
dessert like everything goes against
each other one thing should like so I'm
having a hard time trying to figure out
who this person is so I'm 27 so I'm
thinking this person is a little bit
older than me but not too much older
than me they're definitely not younger
than me so this is carrot cake and this
is their least favorite type of dessert
I think that carrot cake eliminates 20s
and younger because I don't even think
they know what carrot cake is and then I
think it definitely eliminates over 40
because people in their 40s and 50s and
60s love carrot cake I'm not really sure
why the people like vegetables and cake
together but people do and here it is
carrot cake and then we have our last
dessert which is kicker pie they chose
pie they pick pie over cake and that's
not a young people thing to do this is
tough y'all so I think this person I'm
trying to say that they're in their
later 30s or their early
thirty's the number 33 pops out of me
I'm gonna settle on that there 33 final
answer is 33 okay baby right I'm Chris
hey Chris
I'm 23 you are a decade over which one
specifically let us know I just love
reason so much okay you love and I love
oatmeal like when I was younger my
grandma would give me a whole meal to go
to school with yeah everybody would make
fun of me and I would like to drink it
with pride and eat it it's like my thing
so you've got some interesting taste
buds for your age thank you okay so this
is our last contestant this is my last
chance to get this right I've gotten two
out of three roads so I really hope that
I get this one at least close than a
decade apart oh my goodness this person
is my best friend this person is me and
I am them their favorite cookie is
chocolate chip my favorite cookie is
chocolate chip these are really good
people their favorite ice cream is mint
chocolate chip my favorite ice cream is
mint chocolate chip chocolate truffles
is kind of what throws me off because
chocolate truffles got popular in the
70s and 80s but doctors could also mean
that maybe their parents grew up in the
70s and 80s not necessarily they grew up
in the 70s and 80s so it's very possible
that they like chocolate truffles but
I'm interested as to why they didn't
like a brownie because I like brownies
but this isn't about me so they don't
like oatmeal raisin cookies which
further proves my thesis of them being
around my age because people my age we
do not like oatmeal raisin cookies I set
firm on that and then lastly I think
that they're in their late 20s early 30s
because they like cake we're not high
people older generations would probably
prefer a pie I want to say 27 if they're
30 that's cool but I want to say 27
oh no my final answer is 27 hey I'm Kat
Micah and I am 30 I'm so close four
years really really good and I was so
close to saying 30 I realize are you
worried you were going back I feel like
I won this round so thank you so much
Kat for coming I I feel so accomplished
that you're 30 and thank you so much for
watching and look at you next time oh
yes
[Music]